ur tiers dans la vallée du doubs ici les
montbéliard ne sont plus nombreuses que
les habitants et la mairie n'existe pas
pour exercer leur devoir de citoyen les
quatorze électeurs devront se rendre
dans le village d'à côté trois
kilomètres plus loin
ça va pas vous décourager d'aller voter
non non pas du tout non non non je pense
que les élections européennes c'est
important donc il faut il faut
participer
avant il ya quelques temps on n'avait
pas de mérimée on faisait chez de chez
le maire voilà messieurs gare issue dans
son salon voilà exactement ça avait le
côté chaleureux qui peut être
intéressant aussi
comme lors des dernières législatives
dimanche ils voteront à belfahy commune
voisine de 150 habitants pour préparer
cette double élection la municipalité
doit donc s'organiser on peut pas nous
amener des élections mais nous reprocher
quelque chose ne va pas s'il est
obligatoire chaque commune à son nul 1-1
avec son code électoral chacun ses
enveloppes ses tracks publicité urt hier
donc le vote se déroulera pour la petite
commune ici dans notre bureau et
belle-fille pour nous ça sera la petite
salle de convivialité en bas pour
installer les isoloirs urnes et les
bulletins de vote
il faudra pousser les meubles du
secrétariat à deux jours du scrutin il
faut compter et recompter et vérifier
que tout y y et à urt hier l'une des
plus petites communes de franche comté
même privé de bureaux de vote on
s'attend à une participation forte